all right this this is not like a huge
win where we would throw a party
and cheer uh but we actually got some
good news which is that joe biden's a
budget nominee
to run the office of management and
budget near a tandon has had to withdraw
her nomination because of
opposition now from the beginning i said
as we evaluated joe biden's selections
for all sorts of different cabinet and
other positions
nira tandon is a bad pick nira tandon
was joe biden's worst pick
i argued and joe biden selected niro
tandon to run the office of management
and budget
it was pretty clear early on that there
would be opposition not just from many
republicans but possibly even from some
democrats and
indeed that opposition from both
democratic and republican senators
made it clear that she was unlikely to
be able to get confirmed now the reason
let me see how i want to say this
although it's good
that she's not going to go forward and
get confirmed
the reason why most of the republican
and some of the democratic opposition
didn't like her
is kind of a bs reason and it's her
controversial tweets
in which she attacked all sorts of
different people she's attacked and
tweets
everybody from bernie sanders to many
republicans and others
for me the reason nira tandon was a bad
pick was because as someone
affiliated with the center for american
progress she represent
she think about all the things she
didn't represent nira tandon didn't
represent progressivism
niro tandon didn't represent
independence from the most
corporate and establishment interests
within the the democratic party
she represented all of the worst of
democratic party politics an
establishment
uh centrist leaning cow towing to the
money
sort of individual who you were going to
put in charge of the budget
that was the source of my opposition i
didn't care that nira tanden had said
mean things about bernie i didn't care
about niro tandon's other tweets
the reason why so many democrat
republicans and even some democrats like
joe manchin
said that they don't like uh niro tandon
for this position
was mostly related to tweets where all
sorts of different people who clearly
didn't actually have any idea what niro
tandon was tweeting all along
uh sort of decided to grandstand on the
basis of oh look at this tweet that nira
tandon sent look at that tweet that nira
tandon sent
and ultimately it became clear that nira
tandon
didn't have the votes joe manchin an
important
centrist swing vote among democrats in
the senate
said that her quote overtly partisan
statements would have a toxic and
detrimental impact on working
relationships between congress
and the office of management and budget
maine republican
susan collins uh also says that her
quote past actions demonstrated the kind
of animosity biden has pledged to
transcend
and it became clear that they weren't
going to have the votes for her so
this is in a sense funny because on day
one i mean go back to my clip the day
after nira tandon was
nominated i said not only do i think
this is a bad nomination
it's not clear to me she can get
confirmed because i believe there will
be opposition from republicans and
democrats
that's exactly what happened it was
predictable so it's not a huge
win but it's a win in the sense that
this was biden's worst nominee
and she's not going to be in the
position and that's a good thing the
next question becomes
who replaces tandon the front runner is
believed to be shalonda young
a former staff director for the house
appropriations committee
she's been actively pushed by members of
the congressional black caucus
believed to be the replacement pick i
don't know much about
shalonda young we will learn about
shalonda young if indeed she is the
nominee by the time you listen to
today's show maybe she will already have
been made the nominee
uh but as i said before this is not
you know i i don't know where this rank
like
if you said biden could have done covet
relief
10 days in and nira tandon would be
director of office uh the office of
management and budget i might have said
that's a fair trade it would have been
like near attendance bad but i might
have traded it if you got me covered
relief really soon and now we're still
waiting on kobe to relief and it's march
it's a win it's just not feeling
like uh this is now the progressive
takeover of the biden presidency but i
think if
if you want to find something positive
in this
it would be that we can
as people to the left of biden
have an impact on the biden presidency
although again the reason that this
nomination
tanked is partially because republicans
didn't like her mean tweets which is not
exactly a progressive perspective but
that is what it is near attend and not
moving forward and that i can be very
glad about